- What's that for?
- [gasps]
A bucket of...confetti.
- You know what?
I think the night is over.
[indistinct chatter]
- I thought you were
someone else.
- No, no, no. I'm a tutor.
Fro-yo shop, preach!
- No, I'm not doing
any more church bits with you.
- Would it be
too crazy romantical
if I just kissed you
right now?
- Does this answer
your question?
Oh, you have blood.
- What?
Blood?
- Uh-huh.
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
This is really embarrassing.
It happens
when I get too excited.
- No, that's okay.
- Confetti really makes it
a party, no?
- I don't have time
for this conversation right now.
- It's just
a little bit of blood.
Blood, blood.
NCB, abort the mission!
- Not now, Gene.
- Yeah, not ever!
- What's that?
- What's what?
- Hold on.
- No.
- Okay, but--
- Come on, Atty, come on.
- Excuse me, sir.
I think you need
to calm your roll
when speaking to a lady
of such physical beauty.
- Brett, please don't.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
What, son?
You want some of this?
Let me tell you something,
friend.
I Krav Maga daily.
- I'm confused.
Am I your son or your friend?
- We're out of here!
Come on, Atticus.
Let's get your EpiPen. Come on.
- Doesn't make any sense.
- Later, bitch.
- Bitch?
At least I can digest
wheat flour, son.
Well, that's what I get
for listening to Gene,
a backyard full of weirdos
and the guy that I like leaving,
thinking I'm pathetic, which...
I totally am.
- I don't think
you're pathetic.
- Thanks, Brett.
- That guy might though.
Okay, well,
I guess that's my cue
that the evening is over,
so...
- Wait, aren't you gonna
announce the king and queen?
- Are they still doing that?
- Yes.
- Did anyone vote?
- No.
- Cool.
[heavy rock music]
♪ ♪
[eerie music and heartbeats]
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Good-bye.
[clears throat]
And the winner is
Gene and Kerry.
- Confetti!
[suspenseful music]
- No!
[crowd gasps]
- What the [bleep]?
What the [bleep]?
Is it blood?
It's blood?
My bangs is blood!
My bangs blood!
- I am so, so, so, so sorry.
Brett, what did you do?
Why did you drop the blood?
- Drop the blood?
- No!
[all gasp]
Ah.
Why did you have
an extra bucket?
- I got a deal.
- You guys look like
that "Carrie" movie.
- Which movie, Kerry?